[Musica]
uno dei miei preferiti quando
l'adolescente era novecento molti di voi
avranno letto oppure avranno visto il
film la leggenda del pianista
sull'oceano
in soldoni parla di quest uomo di nome
novecento che nasce all'interno di
questa transatlantico che all'inizio del
novecento fa la spola tra la gran
bretagna e new york e lui non scende mai
vive tutta la sua vita dentro il
transatlantico una volta sola ci prova a
scendere ma si blocca metà scaletta
rimane bloccato alla vista della vastità
e della complessità del mondo e quindi
fa una cosa molto intelligente spesso
facciamo tutti noi
rientra dentro e lascia che sia il mondo
che vada da lui a piccole dosi e quindi
a mano a mano che le persone entrano
dentro la nave lui conosce donne artisti
ubriaconi ogni genere di umanità però
all'interno di una struttura che lui
conosce sa decifrare perché cenavo io
adesso non avere un paesino qua vicino
mi sono sempre rivisto molto il
novecento e la sua mi sembrava una
strategia fenomenale per affrontare i
miei dubbi di ragazzo anche io ero
impaurito curioso verso il mondo ma
impaurito e in generale con la paura di
sentirmi sperso nell'affrontare lo per
dirvi mi sono iscritto a un corso di
laurea in inglese quindi concentra tutto
il mondo però qua a siena
è difficile come si fa a scegliere una
strada tra le milioni possibili
ironicamente per scoprire il gusto di
abbracciare nuove situazioni aprirmi al
mondo ci sono dovuta andare a vivere io
su una barca a me è sempre piaciuta
l'idea di fare il ricercatore
penso che perché adesso faccio il
ricercatore insomma un ricercatore alla
scuola superiore sant'anna di pisa
mi occupo di cambiamento climatico e
l'idea che potesse essere pagato per
studiare quello che mi appassionano è
sempre sembrata un'opportunità
incredibile però quando mi sono laureato
qua a siena tre anni fa avevo più dubbi
che i capelli si fa il ricercatore era
una bella idea però anche la rockstar
oppure non lo so avere un barracuda a
questo genere di cose ovviamente non è
che non mi piace fare ricercatore è che
ancora non ho mai deciso chi vuoi essere
mi sentivo un po perso come novecento
comunque ci provo quando mi laureo a
diventare un ricercatore ma non mi
prendono in nessun dottorato o il
massimo dei voti ma non ho nessuna
esperienza all'estero che con una laurea
come la mia è un problema piuttosto
rilevante anche per andare sul mercato
del lavoro
quindi mi trovo nella situazione in cui
si trovano tanti dei ragazzi della mia
età oggi giorno cioè quella di dover
prendere e partire per tornare
chissà quando la di tutte le università
più importanti che potevano darmi una
spinta per alimentare le mie chance di
diventare ricercatore l'unica alla
portata delle mie tasche quel di
amsterdam che è pubblica e quindi la
parte razionale team e fa tutto quello
che deve fare
compì la carta sostiene esami
integrativi alla fine venga ammesso
l'altra parte di me in quella restia al
cambiamento cerca di sabotare mi in
tutti i modi possibili
ma cosa si fa e con due lauree ma perchè
non vai a lavorare ma io mica voglio
fare l'economista voglio suonare la
chitarra da grande cose di questo genere
quando finisco tutte le scuse a mia
disposizione cioè una settimana prima
dell'inizio dei corsi mi decido a fare
due biglietti aerei per amsterdam e uno
per me è uno per la chitarra nel dubbio
e mi ricordo la sensazione di ieri aveva
un carico di paure e anzi industriale la
sensazione che avevo la sera prima di
partire penso che una persona in attesa
di essere ghigliottinata più o meno sia
quella l'idea di lasciare il mio paesino
nei miei affetti tutto quello che
rappresentavano per me mi sembrava così
stupida per poi andare dove
nella mia testa amsterdam era un posto
grigio inospitale e tutti i miei futuri
compagni di corso erano dei brutti ceffi
per competitivi insomma la mia
resistenza al cambiamento era totale
la cosa bella di tutte queste anzi pre
partenza è che poi regolarmente nessuna
si rivela vera e i problemi che ti trovi
ad affrontare sono tutte cose che mai e
poi mai vi sarebbero passate per la
mente come per esempio il dettaglio che
non ho un tetto sopra la testa
in realtà mi avevano offerto una stanza
in una residenza al modico prezzo di 650
euro al mese più 1.200 euro di cauzione
a quel punto loro avrebbero gentilmente
estratto a sorte
in quale residenza sarei andata a finire
e ce n'era una che era insieme a una
prigione uno scherzo
e se non mi andava bene quella estratta
a sorte si tenevano i miei soldi quindi
io dico grazie a dante ma faccio meglio
da solo
piccolo momento sliding door e anche
grosso errore perché come scopro a mie
spese ad amsterdam c'è un sacco d'acqua
e quindi poche case tanta gente quindi
tanta domanda poco offerta risultato
prezzi altissimi
anche dal punto di vista universitario
dall'auto del mio 110 e lode pensavo che
non sarei andato sul velluto ma quasi
e invece corsi sono una mazzata tremenda
ora il sistema olandese universitario e
un po controversa ci vorrebbe un tè da
parte però per oggi vi basti sapere che
hai delle scadenze serratissime e non è
quasi il tempo di dormire figuriamoci da
prendere concerti e infatti l'idea di
fondo non è quella di darti il tempo di
digerire delle nozioni ma di metterti
così tanto sotto pressione che se
sopravvivi ok allora ti meriti una
laurea
quindi io vivacchio in un hotel di
periferia quando arrivò e passo le mie
giornate comprando caffè cappuccino e
birra in giro per amsterdam così da
poter scroccare la linea wifi
così posso studiare e posso cercare
annunci per affittare una casa ma
affittare una casa ad amsterdam è
veramente un'impresa perché banalmente
se devi affittare una casa devi chiamare
per chiamare ti servono sim in olanda
per avere una sim che serve l'indirizzo
di casa comunque rimedi una sim e iniziò
a chiamare ho chiamato ve lo giuro
sicuramente più di 300 annunci mi hanno
fatto vedere una casa sola e ovviamente
non me l'hanno affittata pronto solo uno
studente italiano tutto oppure abbiamo
solo roba sopra i 1000 euro al mese
ci vuole un
uno stipendio come garanzia insomma una
serie di no pazzeschi e le situazione
diventa molto preoccupante e molto poco
tempo per me perché tentano di fra
d'armi in tutti i modi possibili
ovviamente mi rubano addirittura in
camera d'albergo passa più di un mese io
sono ancora alla ricerca di una casa che
non trovo e non sono neanche vicino a
trovare e gli esami sono alle porte
in olanda ti puoi permettere di bocciare
praticamente un esame solo in un anno
perché alla seconda bocciatura hai già
praticamente perso l'anno e io due anni
all'estero proprio non me li potevo
permettere infatti non vengo da una
famiglia ricchissima e quello che mi
faceva più male durante quel periodo era
il pensiero dei sacrifici che stavano
facendo i miei genitori per darmi la
possibilità di prendermi una laurea
all'estero quindi quando inevitabilmente
borso il primo esame della mia vita
chiamò a casa e dico non ce la posso
fare ritorno in italia
altro piccolo momento sulla indoor
fortunatamente i miei genitori mi dicono
di non mollare e un giorno poco tempo
dopo su un sito da cui non avrei
comprato neanche un casco di banane
trovo l'annuncio di una casa barca i
miei compagni ovviamente subito ma dove
vai a inquietante fa freddissimo inverno
io però per la prima volta ho un po
abbandonato le paure e sento il brivido
dell'avventura che un po mi vedeva la
pancia e cioè interna di un po novecento
al contrario
salgo la scaletta e vado a vivere su una
barca penso se non mi danno una casa
andrò a vivere su una barca
eccoci qua dopo un mese più di
vagabondaggio finalmente entro sulla
barca e quando dopo il lungo pensare fai
la scelta giusta
lo senti a pelle e onestamente dire
sulla barca era delizioso non avevo
finestre ma avevo di piccoli oblò non
avevo la camera stava sott'acqua
però
i tramonti erano spettacolari e potevo
fare colazione tutta la mattina tutte le
mattine sulle sulla prua e il vicinato
era una piccola comunità hippy che era
quanto di più simile al mio paesello
avrei potuto desiderare una grande città
europea
insomma le cose iniziano andare bene
era un modo più leggero di di vivere per
esempio i miei compagni di corso
sudamericani che parlano di quel periodo
tanto l'universo taratura e tanto
studiavamo come è l'anno del suo finto
tuttora ma per me grazie a questo
piccolo gesto anti convenzionale anche
un po di fortuna è diventato un anno
meraviglioso e mi ha fatto crescere più
di quante riuscirei a raccontarvi oggi
per esempio la mia casa diventò quasi
subito un punto di incontro per studenti
tutte le serie c erano almeno 15 20
ragazzi studenti parlavano studiavano
ponte si innamoravano pure cucinavano
piatti dei loro paesi appendevano
bandiere insomma una cosa che mi ha
fatto arricchire tantissimo e che non
avrei mai potuto fare in una casa
normale perché non funziona
semplicemente un ragazzo passeggia per
la baia e non deve neanche suonare un
citofono beyonce ha le sue già in casa
tua
era un modo più leggero di vivere e in
generale non dovevo preoccuparmi di un
sacco di piccole cose di cui avrei
dovuto preoccuparmi con una canonica
casa di mattoni e questo mi lasciava un
sacco di energie libere da spendere in
relazioni interpersonali con in cose che
mi appassionavano è in breve inizio a
sentirmi leggero come un palloncino e a
vivere a pelo d'acqua anche io inizio a
provare il piacere di aprirmi a nuove
opportunità a non sentirmi spaventato
dalla complessità e della grandezza del
mondo ma abbracciarla
no questo e dopo
quando quando ti metti in questo genere
di stato mentale succede una piccola
magia che inizia a fare un sacco di cose
in maniera molto più facile di quello
che avresti mai creduto nonostante fosse
operato di lavoro trovo il tempo per
fare tante piccole cose che avevo sempre
voluto fare che non avevamo mai fatto
per esempio avevo sempre voluto scrivere
ma poi pensavo
vabbè lo farò poi oppure ma se non
scrivo bene
oppure chissà cosa penserà a tizio
invece ad amsterdam i metto a scrivere
insieme ad altri ragazzi sparsi in giro
per il mondo come me e mettiamo insieme
questi articoli di società e cultura che
poi raccogliamo in questo sito che poi è
stato chiamato il cartello e che
quest'anno è arrivato quarto ai
macchianera awards come migliore web
agency l'italia finisco addirittura a
fare l'artista di strada
l'avevo sempre voluto fare ma non
l'avrei mai fatto se fosse rimasto nella
mia zona di comfort
quel giorno abbiamo fatto 7 euro che in
olanda sono tre forchette e una birra
piccola alla fine dell'anno grazie a dio
non voglio più nessun esame e mi laureo
facciamo una bellissima gigantesca festa
sulla barca grazie a dio non affondiamo
così io posso accettare la proposta di
dottorato nel frattempo mi è stata fatta
dalla scuola superiore sant'anna e posso
fare il lavoro che volevo fare e posso
tornare a farlo in italia a casa mia
perché la barca era fighissima ma 9
gradi agosto sono una tragedia
tutto questo per dirvi quello che
probabilmente sapete già
ma che troppo spesso tutti quanti ci
scordiamo cioè che i momenti di crisi
paradossalmente sono benedizioni che con
un po di coraggio possono diventare dei
momenti di crescita incredibili io vi
voglio lasciare con quest'ultima storia
che è la mia preferita dell'anno era ho
passato ad amsterdam per chi le
opportunità non hanno era
di tutto il vicinato eccentrico che
fortunatamente avevo il mio preferito da
lui
questo signore ultraottantenne che
viveva nella barca accanto alla mia
quando usciva il sole quelle poche volte
lui prendeva la chitarra si metteva
fuori a suonare fumando una sigaretta
sicuramente lui era nato a londra e
faceva il programmatore per la disney
a un certo punto aveva deciso che londra
non era più casa sua
troppa gente e quindi aveva comprato una
barca e si era messo a vivere ad
amsterdam dove viveva ormai da 30 anni
e così un giorno mentre io facevo
colazione sulla prua e lui stava dando
da mangiare alle anatre sotto la barca
gli dico una cosa che gli volevo dire da
tempo e cioè semplicemente certo però
alla tua età diverse una barca da solo
complimenti non è da tutti e lui mi fa
sì beh da quando mi sono lasciato con la
mia ultima fidanzata 80 anni non riesco
più tanto mi fa fatica a tenere a posto
la barca che teneva come fosse
argenteria per cui prima o poi dovrò
venderla purtroppo però però non ha
ancora perché mi piace un sacco di vere
sulla barca mi sento libero perché se le
cose non vanno poi sempre cambiare aria
non puoi sempre andare via e la mattina
dopo
e vi giuro che è successo mi sveglio
presto perché c'era una ci disse di sole
vado sulla prua
mi volto e la sua barca non c'era più
era partito
grazie a tutti
[Applauso]
[Musica]